when i was thinking about you that whole
thing with lisa coodrow at the time was
you know on friends and she was or maybe
she wasn't even on friends at that point
but she was your girlfriend and she's
the one who said
you have to do saturday night live i
have complete confidence in you that you
can do this
yeah i have to give props to lisa
because i mean i
i have because we've stayed really close
friends but she um
it was such a in in let's see
in 1993
when lauren was toying with the idea of
well maybe
conan could do late night uh i was an
unknown writer
nothing like that had happened in the
history of television i don't think i
mean now
right again this is how much the
business has changed now
if you read they're going to give an
unknown writer
a show on the e network and his name is
uh you know
uh bill jojackovich uh you you would be
like okay whatever
let's see must be good and i'll probably
never hear of it again right but
um at the time people lost their minds
and said what are they talking about you
can't replace letterman with this guy
no one's ever heard of before right and
you had a really funny line which is you
just heard my name
and i remember listening to you back
then and you went conan o'brien why
couldn't they have picked someone from
america
yeah who's this guy like they brought a
guy in from ireland
right and uh and flew him in um yeah
they flew him in
and um and lisa said to you like lisa
said
lisa said and i had i had many people in
my life going i don't know
man you can't letterman you can't i mean
you're funny but that's letterman you
can't and i kind of felt the same way
i'm not crazy i felt
i i was i was down two thirds
i had my had strong doubts and lisa
kudrow
was adamant and she just kept saying
you're the perfect person to do it
you're going to do it it's going to be a
big success wow
this is what you're destined to do and
she wouldn't she wouldn't get out of my
grill about it
and she just stuck to it and uh
so i actually sort of
i drafted off her confidence i drafted
off
her i said well lisa thinks i can do it
so i'm gonna go with that